alors fabrice luchini vous avez déclaré
le pire c'est évidemment la télévision
elle peut rendre antipathique ans alors
qu'on a tout simplement le trac mais
quand on a tourné un film il faut bien
les défendre alors l'occurrence et un
record c'est un spectacle vous avez le
trac vous à la télé non
oui faut bien sûr on peut dire un gros
carré ouais j'ai fait une ou deux
émissions avec fabrice et j'ai un peu
une ou deux émissions je sais un peu
comment il fonctionne c'est qu'il arrive
toujours tout timide et ré où il dit un
mot puis un deuxième et à la fin il
rachète la production qui parle et il va
chanter adamo dans cinq minutes
c'est une collaboration délicate pour
vous parce que ce qui aurait pu se
passer quand on était pas
encore été pas mal parce que ça fait une
émission de t c'est un
tu vas tenir adamo quand même là
maintenant qu s'est vendu comme ça je
suis malheureuse mais si si moi je suis
moi je demande de l'accent pieds noirs
moi je suis d'abord très très heureux
d'abord avant tout d'être avec d'être
près de vous qui avez fait un film
immense je le redis didier grand film
n'essayez pas de m'embrouiller
alors allez-y
donc fabrice luchini vous reprenez à
partir du 4 décembre de spectacles au
théâtre de la madeleine oui un week-end
un véritable succès populaire commune
gens sont venus déjà le voit ça fait 450
ou 500 présentations ça doit faire deux
cent mille personnes deux cent mille
personnes et là c'est déjà il paraît
enfin sceller les patrons du théâtre de
la madeleine qui disent ça c'est que les
gens quand ils ont su que ça allait
commencer ils ont déjà téléphoner pour
réserver avant même qu'ils aient de la
promotion ou qu'ils aient des affiches
dans paris c'est vrai oui un peu un
petit peu un petit peu vrai c'est pas
cher à ces sont des premières places en
tassant francs aux mille et les chairs
sont à 200
à 210 on vous entend et sang froid
on vous voit
les moyennement cher et sont
quand vous dites des textes d'hugo de
baudelaire de nietzsche de la fontaine
de céline on peux nous en dire un petit
bout céline dion avec
une en pas tout de suite donc je pense
que ça va se détendre il y a pas
d'étendre notre ami
non mais choquant plus en général c'est
quelqu'un qui est ici des citations à un
moment précis dans un contexte
particulier que parfois on lui a
reproché ce soit de la pédanterie qu'en
fait je pense que c'est plus une forme
d'humilité et que quand les autres quand
on n'est pas content on peut pas trouver
les mots pour le dire et quand d'autres
personnes vont très bien dit je trouve
que c'est l'ambiance se détend et elle
s'élève surtout a donc c'est derrière
que quand même grâce à ça vous
mademoiselle comme toujours souvent à
part les artistes et véritable écart les
artistes véritable qui ont une grosse ou
non pas top mais une énorme féminité dès
qu'on est face aux halles et héros qui
veut tout de suite faire le brillant sap
sap longue quand une femme parle ça
élève ou alors quand on a un metteur en
scène de talent tout d'un coup
l'ambiance est bonne on a un compliment
quand on rend ton rantissi ya baffie
qu'immédiatement entravent le mouvement
des pêcheurs refusent de venir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu